- [Voiceover] All right,
this is the fourth and final
in a series of videos about how to tackle
the DBQ or document-based question
on the AP U.S. History exam.
We started out by reading
all of the documents
that are provided in the exam,
from which we are to write an essay
that analyzes the major changes
and continuities in the social
and economic experiences
of African Americans
migrating from the rural South,
to urban areas in the North
in the period 1910 to 1930.
As we analyzed these primary documents,
we kind of identified three major themes
that we wanna talk about.
And that was cultural differences
between the South and the North,
differences in the type of labor
and differences in patterns of segregation
in the South and the North.
And from these themes we
came up with a thesis,
which was more or less
that the more things change,
the more things stay the same.
So even though African Americans moved
to a whole new city, a
whole new environment,
a whole new system of labor,
they couldn't escape persistent racism,
which had similar effects
on their lives in the North
as it did in the South.
Now we're at the writing the essay part.
And while obviously I can't sit here
and write a whole essay on the screen,
I do wanna outline things for you,
and give you a general sense
of what you could talk about where.
For the DBQ we're gonna do
a standard five-paragraph essay,
which means introduction. . .
with a thesis statement,
paragraph 1,
paragraph 2, paragraph 3.
These will all be the body paragraphs
where we'll give our evidence
in support of our thesis.
And then a conclusion,
which wraps up what we've said before,
and really drives home our point.
In this essay, to get full credit,
you should expect to use
either all, or all but one
of the primary documents
that are provided.
And that means you need
to reference them all,
although you don't necessarily
have to go into detail
about every single one of them.
And what I want to
caution you against doing
is just talking about
each piece of evidence
one after another
without putting them into a
larger framework of ideas.
So don't just say oh well
first their was a folk saying
about the effect of the boll
weevil and sharecropping
on black Southerner's lives
and then some of them asked
for help moving North.
They wrote to the Chicago defender,
because you don't want
to just let this evidence
lead you along.
What you want to do instead is say
that you have read these
pieces of evidence,
you have analyzed them,
and now you're going synthesize them
into an argument of your own.
This is where the themes come in handy,
because we've taken the time to see
what's going on in all of these documents
and kind of bubble up to the surface
what are the real important issues
that people are talking about.
And as we thought about
changes and continuities,
in those things,
the thesis that we came
up with was more or less
that even though the form
of each of these things changed,
the form of the culture,
the form of the labor,
the form of the segregation,
the underlying problem of
racism kind of remained.
So this thesis actually gives
us a really neat structure
for the rest of the essay
because we've said the forms changed,
but the underlying
problem stayed the same.
So for each of these body
paragraphs we'll talk
first, about the change in form,
but then we'll talk about
the underlying problems
that stay the same.
All right, are you ready to
take a stab at writing this?
Let's kind of ease into
things with our introduction.
I think a good thing for us to do
might be to set the scene a little bit.
And we talked about some
of the historical events
that were going on at this time period.
So you might say that sharecropping
had really been an economic loss
for African Americans.
And so they were feeling the pressure,
both from the system of sharecropping,
where 50% of what they got
was sent back to landowners,
and also from the boll weevil,
which had killed off a
considerable amount of the crop.
So they just weren't doing ok.
You could also mention that in the 1890s,
the Supreme Court case
Plessy versus Ferguson
had made separate but equal accommodations
legal for blacks and for whites,
which basically put
racism as part of the law.
So if there had been any hope remaining
that the Civil War and reconstruction
were going to result in
a society in the South
that was not based on
racial discrimination,
it was kind of destroyed
with Plessy versus Ferguson,
at least for the time being.
And then lastly you might
say that World War One,
As the United States
mobilized for the war,
led to many new factory jobs in the North,
which gave African Americans in the South
an opportunity to leave.
At the end of your first
paragraph in the introduction,
this is the time to bring out your thesis.
Our thesis is even
though African Americans
who moved from the South to the North
in the period 1910 to 1930
experienced tremendous changes,
in the culture surrounding them,
the work that they did,
and their living patterns,
they still suffered from
many of the same problems
that they had suffered from in the South
due to the pervasive influence of racism.
In a way what you're saying here is
that racism was a national
problem in the United States.
It didn't change from north to south.
So even though the form that racism took
might be different in
South Carolina and Chicago,
there was no real qualitative difference
in it's impact on the
lives of African Americans.
This is where we break out our themes.
Our first theme was about
cultural differences.
Remember our structure.
First we're gonna talk about
the things that were different,
and then we're gonna talk about the things
that stayed the same.
One thing that was different would be
that if sharecroppers moved to the city,
they were moving from a rural
to an urban environment.
Where many African Americans in the South
had worked as sharecroppers
and lived in a farming situation,
now they were headed to
the heart of the city
where they might be surrounded
by other African Americans.
Bring up the map from document 7 here.
And they were also worried
about what it would be like
to take a job in the city,
somewhere that was completely
far away from home.
And this would be a part
where you might consider talking
about the newspaper letter
in document 2,
where a man writes to the Chicago defender
asking for help because he's
afraid he might get hoodwinked.
So what are some of the
things that stayed the same?
Well I think we can definitely
say that some of their fears
were justified about the move to the city,
because many people
found that life there was
just as hard as it was in the South
and we see this in this document
about the Cotton Belt Blues.
We might even say on kind
of a larger cultural level,
that white people in the North were
no more kind to them than
white people in the South.
And here you might consider
bringing up document number six,
the one about the race riot in Chicago.
That's a paragraph about
cultural differences.
How about labor differences?
In our second paragraph
we're gonna talk about
how even though African Americans
moved to a completely
different type of labor,
from sharecropping to factory work,
they still faced pervasive
racism in the factory system
that led to whites rioting
and also segregated facilities,
even bathroom facilities
in these workplaces.
The thing that changes
is the type of labor,
and here you might wanna
bring up the first document
where you're talking about sharecropping.
So what kind of work they
were doing was different,
but the same kind of problems they faced
in the workplace were quite similar.
They faced segregation in the workplace,
and they faced
stereotypes about the
kind of work they did
and whether or not they were good workers.
And here you might bring
up the third article,
where the efficiency expert talks about
how it's important to separate
white and black workers
so that you don't have any kind
of racial friction in your office.
And you might also talk
about the sixth article,
where they say that many people believe
that African American workers
were used as scabs in strikes.
So that's a kind of a way
of separating the races
that's saying that white workers in unions
might be undermined by black laborers
willing to work for less.
Lastly we're talking about
the experience of segregation.
We've already mentioned this transition
from a rural to an urban environment,
but you might also talk about
how living patterns changed.
In the South, African Americans and whites
usually lived in similar places,
in the same town, in
the same parts of town,
more or less,
but the way that they used
space was slightly different.
For example, African
Americans were often expected
to use the servant's entrance,
sit either at the back of a movie theater,
or maybe not even go into the same places
as a white person.
But in Chicago,
there is an entire African
American neighborhood,
And for this you definitely wanna
bring up document 7,
which shows where African Americans
were living in Chicago.
And the thing that stays the same
is really the system
of segregation itself.
Northern segregation looks different,
but it's still segregation,
so you might talk about,
I mean this is still segregation
is one thing you can say.
And you can also say
that there's kind of a
implicit promise of violence
if African Americans step out of line
in the system of segregation.
And here you might talk
about document number four,
which is this kind of
snearing newspaper article
from a white newspaper in Mississippi,
saying oh well in Mississippi
we have lynching,
in the North they have explosions.
Their point was
"Oh, well isn't lynching better?"
But for the purposes of your essay
what you can really say is
"What's the difference?"
They're both forms of death
for getting out of line
in a system of racism.
So there's nothing that's really
all that different there anyway.
And now we're at the conclusion.
Generally I would advise you
against bringing up any new information
in a conclusion because
you want your reader
to come away saying
"Oh yea, that was right!"
not "Wait a minute, the author didn't talk
about that in the essay at all,
why are they mentioning
it in the conclusion?"
So I would advise you
to just kind of restate
what you've been talking about
throughout the essay saying
that even though there is
this vast transformation,
in the culture, the living situations,
the work of African
Americans who are moving
from the South to the North,
the substantive problem
of racism stayed the same.
All right, well that's it for the DBQ.
Taking the time to do your due diligence
and understanding these documents,
and coming up with an
idea and a structure,
and even an outline,
will really pay off in the long run,
because it will help you to write an essay
that is really strong and really clear.